astrazeneca has had a remarkable year
one of innovation and frustration speed
and speed bumps
pressure and politics the company has to
catch up
but all of it leading ultimately to this
millions of jabs in millions of arms
saving thousands of lives confidence in
astrazeneca
hasn't evaporated people are still
coming still keen to get jabbed but
there are valid questions
about what this has cost the company
prior to the pandemic astrazeneca had
limited experience in vaccinations
and unlike others they agreed to deliver
this job at
cost in the face of no profit a very
rocky share price
and a barrage of bad headlines many
investors may well be asking
was it all worth it many close to the
company
insist it was but don't underplay the
effort put in
and the toll taken i can't imagine how
much time and effort it's taken from the
executive from the board
all the way through the company to
develop a vaccine at such low cost
so quickly it will have been herculean
do you think people inside the company
might think they've had a particularly
unfairly hard time yes
i suspect some people do feel they've
had a bit of a hard time i think i would
do if i was on the board at the present
time
i spoke to a couple of the executives
and they said look this has been the
most difficult thing we've ever done
but i just said look at the millions of
lives you've probably saved
there's been criticism on a number of
fronts astrazeneca struck its deal with
oxford university a year ago
confusion followed the trial results in
november due to data inconsistencies
the uk approved the vaccine in december
the eu followed shortly
but by late january astrazeneca told the
eu it wouldn't deliver all promised
doses starting an intense diplomatic row
and then in march 10 countries paused or
limited roll out
following reports of rare blood clots
eu fury about supply problems has been
palpable some say astra was a scapegoat
caught in the tailwinds of a slow
rollout and brewing vaccine nationalism
but others blame breakneck speed saying
broken promises and errors in data
communication
were avoidable mistakes alex advises
some of the world's top pharma companies
he says reputation is recoverable but it
may put others off
if you look at what's going on right now
would any other pharma company that
currently doesn't have a vaccine
business
follow azad's route when your share
price is lower than it was a year ago
and when you're seeing yourself on the
front pages time and again
the answer has to be no which is sad
because what astrazeneca has done has
been brilliant
it's going to get bumpy but at the end
of it in the long game
they will be remembered as one of the
companies that help save the world
countries from germany australia and
most recently france have further
restricted who should receive the
astrazeneca jab
however confident the corporate campaign
in the end
public confidence is king helenan smith
sky news